Grand chest has different time controls
rapid bleit and Classics how do you
adjust your playing style or strategy
depending on the time control yeah it's
very different going from one time
control to the other I think I I mean I
just got back from is man so switching
from classical to Rapid might be tricky
so I think it's important to play some
training games to sort of adjust to that
and then yeah sort of go from there uh
so yeah I really enjoy playing rapid and
Blitz it's much shorter than classical
and lot less stressful usually you have
more fun playing I think the main
difference is when there's less time on
the clock you can take more risks
because the opponent doesn't have much
time to punish you so uh I think that's
basically how most people play they play
a lot more aggressive more tactical
games than usual and that's probably
what I'll try to do as well yeah by now
I'm used uh to this mix of time control
so you know I try to know what I do best
and I play fast and put pressure so of
course that's obviously easier buing
rapid and in Blitz some I've been
struggling in the Blitz in the last few
tournaments of plate I've been doing
better in the rapid um that didn't used
to be the case uh but I prepared
specifically for for the bleed as well
um because I feel this uh first
tournament will be important I like the
format because you play all kind of
chest so and adjusting to it is kind of
easy because the tournaments are a bit
look like longer like
forance one is in June one is in July so
you can just slowly but um in general
I'm big fan of the format you play all
kind of Chess and you will see who's the
best at the end yeah this is this is a
definitely a challenge to do uh not only
for the players I think it's fun to try
some different things but also probably
for the people watching it's interesting
to see some Blitz and some some rapid
and uh because they all have their own
peculiarities so um and we see some guys
who are more uh i' say more motivated
for some time controler for others
because they enjoy it more so it it'll
definitely be interesting to see yeah I
mean takes a while to get used to it
definitely I think it's a very different
game between speed chess and classical I
guess as I heard from another player he
just got to keep improving on chess you
know try to play your own game try to
play better and what you turn in
classical will hopefully move itself to
Rapid and blit yeah I'm very bad at
adjusting my style usually um I'm always
like one step behind so after I finish
the rapid tournament I'm like I figure
out how to play the rapid and then
already Blitz and I'm too slow and then
I'm like just in the mood for the Blitz
and then comes the classical and I'm
kind of uh too fast again so I'm always
a step behind but I'll I'll try I don't
think really you know this sort of
adjustment works at all it's just about
your your condition if it's good is good
if it's not then then Alice well for me
here it's just rapid and Blitz so I
guess I don't have to adjust that much
although there's still some adjustment
between rapid and Blitz I think for me
Blitz is easier because I play Blitz way
more often even just casually rapid is
difficult I think uh somehow it's in
between classic and Blitz and those are
the two that I play more commonly so for
me it's difficult to adjust so I think
the only way is to just uh play more
games and practice more so lately I have
been practicing this quite a bit I play
some title Tuesdays something online um
rapbit I have not been playing that much
U mainly CH chesto event and also in
bill in July this year I play some RIT
there and as well as World Cup but um
I'm very excited to see how I would do
because I haven't play such a strong uh
tournament in Rapid and bl for a long
[Music]
time